- Three, two.
(knife thudding)
Wait, there's a food processor?
Hey, what's up everyone.
My name is Tway,
and welcome to a whole new
season of "Making It Big."
The show where I turn your
favorite foods, giant.
- What?
- Oh, my God.
- This is so big.
- Oh!
- I'm a chef and content creator.
I share really easy-to-follow recipes,
most of them being
Vietnamese recipes because...
(speaking in foreign language)
This is so much flour.
This next step is going to be insane.
Everything that I do basically
revolves around food.
It's definitely safe
to say that I love food
and I love my culture.
I'm really proud of myself.
I'm nervous.
I'm taking some of my favorite
recipes, whether it's my own,
or classics that I grew up
eating and making it big.
This is going to be huge.
I knew it was gonna be
big, but this is big.
Make sure to subscribe
and follow me for updates
because you don't wanna
miss out on this season.
(rock music)